good morning progress there - yeah I
slept in my clothes don't work today
that's great lighting that looks great
that looks great you look great
hi Padma guess what it's still blog man
I'm probably covering some fish a
microphone I don't know where it is on
this camera allowed Mystics blog man and
I'm going to meet it and I'm wearing a
sweatshirt with hosting I want the
people in this meeting to know that I
can only give a certain amount of not
only wearing a sweatshirt but my a
sweatshirt with intentional holes and
it's on brand because both of my thing
same it's to vlog missile augment don't
log my first meeting done went really
well
lovely woman I got a bottle of water
life is interesting as [ __ ] the Toyota
driving in front of me with a giant
soccer decal on it
I hate after you play soccer I guess you
look like you play soccer click an angle
right to tell people vlogs this angle I
show you all of me transparency and then
an electrician is coming to fix my
outlet for my dryer so I can wear other
clothes and I bleed bedsheets well maybe
we'll eat some food I don't know Danny
just got crazy
[Music]
like this like this like this I did not
lie he loves ding Pet not a good body
that is a comforter that I could not fit
into memories washer when I was washing
clothes at her place the other day the
electrician is currently in my home
switching an outlet goose is locked in
the back of the house sequestered just
screaming through the walls at the
electrician super fun time they're
having and I'm off to my second meeting
of the day angle change I know it's
really [ __ ] cold
how's your day storage some long he'll
jump cutting your mouth
haha also I love you I love you I love
you I don't know when like I said it
last I love you don't the Internet where
it means absolutely nothing like science
format bogus update I've been looking
for a pockets not for five years five
full years in this parking garage what
are you all doing here why are Kong here
what this is I hate parking and parking
garages I mean I don't hate it I just
thought I straight-up lied to you I
don't hate it I don't love it and taking
a chance that my eyes don't deceive me
tiny car in a spot you also mini coopers
ooh there's one found one I just heard
it
[Music]
that's symbolism or is that symbolism
asking for a friend why look coming
chair for the best music video alright
now I yeah I am waiting for tonight whoa
have a couple minutes before I go up to
the meeting which means I'm gonna spruce
my engrosses face up the paintings for
the company I believe it's pronounced
epic me this morning had one woman in it
she was absolutely this meeting
apparently has numerous people in it
it's always fun to try to make no eye
contact with multiple people eyeball
start working like they're in a pinball
machine and just like that our meeting
is done but a lovely group of happy
people that was
this is a good this is good do you ever
drive that was that that was a question
go ahead thank you I'm going this right
to the exit we just had a standoff I
think we're married now yep I'm out of
parking garages and you're just like is
this how did this get bill who
engineered this what is this a sure
painting that I'm exiting from right now
how does this work why just food for
thought nom nom nom I'm driving again
I'm driving I'm driving again I'm
driving I love you I'm driving still
better I'm eating chips
Bogg mess Oh oh my god it's disgusting
isn't it flat you mean are you busy
being cute yeah cute how's your day been
oh my god so Oh sitting at my desk my
tongue hurts because I think I've been
eating too much salt lately life is
crazy I feel like my tongue has blisters
all over I feel like I might have the
plague kiyotaka 30 right now I have a
meeting at 8:00 with some writers to
talk about script business business
business business entertainment industry
pretty much about scripts
what an update oh wait right now I'm
just reading a bunch of other script
block man this is this is how um here's
what makes my face look slightly less
potato but like Jim very much potato
those new emojis came out today
treat your sales they're a burrito and I
got someone doing a facepalm if that's
not my religion it's not I'm not I can't
be I can't religious sighs burry doesn't
facepalm emojis but sure dumb kidding I
love you okay great lighting perfect
nighttime vlogmas
the car has antlers on it and I just
can't loose with it doesn't stop but she
does it red lights have to be tighter so
excited that's a great update Robert De
Niro is back from this drink meeting
she's thrilled
yeah end of vlogmas day two I'm gonna
edit this video do some other stuff
maybe not masturbate if any of you
thought that that's that minute no I
meant like watch Real Housewives that's
also not my term for masturbating
watching Real Housewives is just exactly
as it sounds did the land just get a
hand okay GUP beach balls covered in
baby oil right now if you guys enjoyed
this youtube channel i'm doing vlogmas
just like everyone else's to of love
mess because the
a bandwagon I strap myself to it and I
just pull others off of it so I can get
right on it very destructive make me
your friend I don't know also I want to
show you guys this wrong text message
conversation I got hey are you on your
way I've been standing here for 40
minutes just let me know if you're
coming or not so I know what to do oh
and call the girls at the hotel they
wanted a ride or something you have the
wrong number
oh who is this this is a Nikki's number
nope sorry AM okay then like 10 minutes
later well polite stranger the city is
crazy I'm completely lost and can't
reach my friends so yeah I'm not weird
just a little desperate yeah I feel
really bad for this person I think I
might text them back something I don't
know exactly what yet I'm gonna text
them after I get I'd to go that knows to
it